and three to never know where a good
ideas gonna come from good ideas are
like a mouse in your house you know he's
there you don't know when you're gonna
see them or where it's gonna be so you
just set lots of traps and just be
patient
[Music]
we are the artistic directors of
Pilobolus we're in a Jaworski and mapkit
Pilobolus started in 1971 up at
dartmouth it was started by four men who
had no dance training it's a dance
company traditionally we make things
with our bodies and that can go from
dances to being part of theatrical
productions to what a lot of people see
online our shadow work as the artistic
directors we're trying to bring the
group together around a shared vision
one of the great things about having
partners that while one of us is totally
in the moment the other person is going
on what should we do next or like
already kind of in that editing process
the performers like their job is to just
be interested in everything sometimes
you have to like kind of bring people in
because they're gonna just keep
generating you have to go wait no do
that that's the one let's work on that a
lot of people identify Pilobolus with
the idea that when you brought pilobolus
dancers together you couldn't tell where
one body started and the other one
started with shadow it's sort of the
same thing
you're just overlapping them in the
shadow and you don't know where one's
head is and where one's butt is so it's
the same type of physicality just
explode when you started working with
shadows we didn't really know what the
rules were so you're playing with this
new medium and slowly discovering these
very simple rules when you move closer
to the light source you get bigger
move towards the screen and get smaller
we have a cone of light that we call
that's the cone that's made from the
light that shines out how do you come in
and out of that code was a big part of
the discussion he also started to
realize that we could use not just our
bodies but cloth and props and we can
make things look 3d when they're not
really 3d so the more we played in it
the more the rules started to open up
and we had more of a vocabulary to work
with in to see the human bodies first
and then see the image clickin is
magical we found that if we shortcut
that then some of the magic gets lost
getting into place is usually a role in
we have Coronas just prior to the
creation and a corona is something that
sprays out word before it comes together
to create the composite image then we
have the composite image and then the
roll out at the end seven principles
one of them is to understand what is
flat depending on where you are in fact
in order to make people look straight
sometimes they have to be in a kind of
weird position if you look at the flower
the guy that's at the top he's leaning
back so that he can match everybody else
you can shorten or lengthen a body part
by moving it slightly toward the screen
or slightly away from the screen we use
clothes that have stretch to them so
that we can expand and create the
bellies and stuff like that as you get
closer to the projector your image gets
larger and larger as you get closer to
the screen your image gets smaller and
smaller so if you bring two people from
the center and they start to move apart
you can give the illusion that one is
growing or one is shrinking
when you're making these composite
sheets there's a whole other kind of
dance of choreography that happens on
the other side there are times that
literally people are in a shape and
they're and your final job and you're in
some weird thing is to take your hand
and go because you're covering some tiny
little pinprick of light that's ruining
it
the amount of teamwork that the dancers
and the performers have if there's one
person who's not paying attention the
whole thing I'm crashing down everybody
has to pay attention and sort of be
watching each other's back
[Music]
good roohani portail meaty what about
this I think well let's go
[Music]
so people it's like okay yeah let's do
that
yeah oh here we go coming out and the
Isles opening up
- left to the right
[Music]
oh wow I think we just like an ice dome
with like a flattop like these two
little we need three mags we can let's
focus on the head cuz that's the
identifier
[Music]
limitations are awesome for creativity
they are super helpful because if the
world is your oyster then it's really
hard to make a decision but when there
are limitation is there are rules and
you work within those rules and suddenly
you have to be creative to sort of Bend
those rules and push the boundaries of
what is possible in that world when
we're tackling a new idea or a challenge
we don't have one person who's directing
the group our ideas come from all the
peripheral and as they coalesce into the
center that's when they start to merge
and that's when you start to see what it
actually is the information isn't always
at the beginning the information
sometimes it's all the way at the end
and that informs the rest of the piece
or it's somewhere in the middle or it's
like in this little moment that doesn't
even end up in the piece but somehow it
informed what we were doing sometimes
we'll be putting something together and
it's just not clicking we'll look at it
we'll be like yes that sort of looks
like an elephant but there's a defining
element that's missing and we can't
figure out what that is and sometimes
it's the way the thing moves sometimes
it's a very specific detail it's like
the eating of the hay like when the
elephant eats it's not really necessary
but like just to watch the trunk see the
mouth and then that paint just
disappears
it makes you feel like it's got a vote
like it went someone I think it's about
being agile and responding in real-time
to what's happening in the room and
what's happening with the performers
that you're working with recognizing
when an idea is working and when it's
not and being able to change course yeah
that's the ability part of it and it's
kind of like maddening yeah sometimes
cuz you're kind of like balancing from
this like crazy optimism to like that's
never gonna work to this is it you also
have to be willing to fail that's how a
guard against mediocrity
[Music]
it's fun to be able to bring delight
most of the time you're not enjoying
what you're doing and what you have to
do on the day-to-day so to be able to
enjoy it and to allow other people to
enjoy it and invite other people to
enjoy it is very special without the
audience and they're like the last
collaborators for us they're the thing
that makes it crack we need them to make
it be a bobble show
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm David Kwan and I'm gonna show you
how to make a crossword puzzle puzzles
are all around us there are problems
everywhere but a good puzzle makes the
solver feel smart as an enigma tist
somebody who performs puzzles I'm
presenting them to you I'm challenging
your brain getting you to think outside
the box and hopefully have that aha
moment when you can feel smart
[Music]